It is almost Thanksgiving, and do I have a recipe for you.
It's a beautiful roast with stuffing,
my favorite food, and why we only have it once a year,
is not okay with it.
I guess that makes me appreciate it more,
but I could eat stuffing 365,
and I also live for gravy,
like a good, rich, hearty, deep brown, roux driven gravy,
but I have a twist.
This one's completely meatless, and you will not
even know the difference.
Quorn is a company that is actually global,
and it has come here to this country,
and I am the new CMO, that's chief mom officer.
(crowd cheering)
That's right.
And I care about the messaging and the marketing
and the branding, and I am addicted to this product
and I believe in it, and now our show
is working with them too, and they have a selection of
delicious meat-free products that are available nationally
at Whole Foods, and then the frozen meatless section
at several other grocery stores around the country.
This is very accessible
(crowd cheering)
and I find it unparalleled in taste, integrity,
it is something that I'm very proud to be a part of
this company, my kids and I eat it.
And so first, this is Quorn's meatless, vegetarian turkey.
It is so easy to prepare, you just preheat your oven
to 425 degrees and you place it on parchment paper,
and you put it on a baking sheet.
If it's frozen, it's about 55 minutes.
If it's thawed out it's about 50,
and then we're gonna prepare a mushroom gravy
in this pot.
All right, our heat is on.
So, I have sauteed down these mushrooms with shallot
and a little olive oil with the butter,
so the butter doesn't burn.
And do not salt your mushrooms until the last minute,
because it actually leeches the water out.
So it completely changes the dynamic of them.
So once they're cooked,
you want to give them that salt and pepper.
So we're gonna make a roux right here,
and I'm gonna put the flour in,
and then I'm just gonna mix that together
for about two minutes until it kind of all coalesces
and congeals and coats.
Never met a roux I didn't love.
(crowd laughs)
And then the next step you would take is adding in
your white wine.
Then I'm gonna add, the next step is my stock.
Oopsy daisy, that's right, yeah, there we go.
Yeah, I'm not perfect in the kitchen,
nor do I ever act like it.
The new book is called rebel homemaker for a reason.
(crowd laughs)
(crowd applauds)
You know,
if I'm laughing and my hair is on fire and I'm enjoying
myself and I'm happy, that's how it works and looks
in the kitchen at my house.
All right, so I just added tamari,
which is so amazing, salty, umami, delicious.
It also brings a beautiful color and helps add that richness
to the gravy.
And then you're just gonna take a little bit of herbs,
parsley, sage, and thyme, and I'm gonna throw it in,
I'm gonna bring it down to a simmer,
and I'm gonna go for about 10 minutes.
And then, we have a chef that works with Quorn,
the great Stephen, and he had this great idea to put
your stuffing in a waffle maker,
and I was like, "oh yeah.
Oh yeah, I can get into that."
So again, I love a classic stuffing.
And, what Palar brought the idea to this dish,
was adding dried cranberries in it.
And, because this does go in a waffle maker,
I did love the idea of the subliminal sweetness,
'cause we think of waffles as something that we put syrup on
and we're going with a savory gravy,
so the dried cranberries give that little pop.
So, now that we've got all this, I'm just gonna show you
what an end result will be.
I'm moving everything to the side.
Here is my end result of my gravy.
One thing that I really love about this gravy too,
it has really large pieces of mushroom,
which, if you're a vegetarian, by the way,
your mushroom is your best friend.
So, basically here you go, you can do this,
you can move your little waffle, and then I'm gonna
struggle to get these on the plate, and,
see, okay, yeah.
(crowd applauds)
But,
so,
here is my take
(crowd cheering)
on a, see what I did, I ran out of gravy.
Oh, well.
It's all gonna go in the same place anyway.
But I'm just so excited to be working as the new CMO
of Quorn, and this is our first dish that we're making
on the show, and it'll be the first of many.
To any parents out there, or nugget lovers,
I've never had nuggets this amazing in my life.
There is no soy in this product.
It's so wonderful, and they have so many different
types of products.
I am so proud and excited to bring this Thanksgiving
alternative to you.
(crowd cheering)
So make sure you go TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com for the full
recipe, and for the perfect picky eaters in your house,
try these nuggets!
(cheering continues)
We'll be right back.
(upbeat music plays)